Ông chủ Tôi sợ chết mất Giữa đêm khuya thế này Ông chủ Tôi sợ chết mất
Giữa đêm khuya thế này Nếu anh không có việc gì quan trọng Ông chủ Tôi sợ chết mất Giữa đêm khuya thế này Nếu anh không có việc gì quan trọng
Anh sắp chết rồi Tôi sợ chết mất Giữa đêm khuya thế này Nếu anh không có việc gì quan trọng Anh sắp chết rồi Thật là có Giữa đêm khuya thế này
Nếu anh không có việc gì quan trọng Anh sắp chết rồi Thật là có Anh bị điên à
Tin hay không tùy anh, tôi sẽ cho anh nghỉ việc Anh sắp chết rồi Thật là có Anh bị điên à Tin hay không tùy anh, tôi sẽ cho anh nghỉ việc
Tôi sẽ cho anh nghỉ việc Thật là có Anh bị điên à Tin hay không tùy anh, tôi sẽ cho anh nghỉ việc Tôi sẽ cho anh nghỉ việc Anh tưởng mỗi mình anh biết chửi người à
Anh bị điên à Tin hay không tùy anh, tôi sẽ cho anh nghỉ việc Tôi sẽ cho anh nghỉ việc Anh tưởng mỗi mình anh biết chửi người à
Anh tưởng có tiền là có thể Tin hay không tùy anh, tôi sẽ cho anh nghỉ việc
Tôi sẽ cho anh nghỉ việc Anh tưởng mỗi mình anh biết chửi người à
Anh tưởng có tiền là có thể Bỏ qua tội lỗi của người khác à Tôi sẽ cho anh nghỉ việc Anh tưởng mỗi mình anh biết chửi người à
Anh tưởng có tiền là có thể Bỏ qua tội lỗi của người khác à Thật là điên rồi Anh tưởng mỗi mình anh biết chửi người à Anh tưởng có tiền là có thể Bỏ qua tội lỗi của người khác à
Thật là điên rồi Trợ lý của anh bị sao vậy Anh tưởng có tiền là có thể Bỏ qua tội lỗi của người khác à
Thật là điên rồi Trợ lý của anh bị sao vậy Tôi ghét tỏi nhất Bỏ qua tội lỗi của người khác à
Thật là điên rồi Trợ lý của anh bị sao vậy Tôi ghét tỏi nhất Bây giờ tôi không cho phép anh thích nữa
Tôi muốn tôi thích Trợ lý của anh bị sao vậy Tôi ghét tỏi nhất Bây giờ tôi không cho phép anh thích nữa
Tôi muốn tôi thích Anh muốn làm gì Tôi ghét tỏi nhất Bây giờ tôi không cho phép anh thích nữa Tôi muốn tôi thích Anh muốn làm gì Tôi sẽ bắt anh đi ăn tỏi
Bây giờ tôi không cho phép anh thích nữa Tôi muốn tôi thích Anh muốn làm gì Tôi sẽ bắt anh đi ăn tỏi
Anh đứng lại Tôi muốn tôi thích Anh muốn làm gì Tôi sẽ bắt anh đi ăn tỏi
Anh đứng lại Tôi sẽ không tha cho anh đâu Anh muốn làm gì Tôi sẽ bắt anh đi ăn tỏi Anh đứng lại Tôi sẽ không tha cho anh đâu
Tế bào ung thư của anh Anh đứng lại Tôi sẽ không tha cho anh đâu
Tế bào ung thư của anh Đã phát triển đến giai đoạn cuối Tôi sẽ không tha cho anh đâu Tế bào ung thư của anh Đã phát triển đến giai đoạn cuối
Có khả năng nào Tế bào ung thư của anh Đã phát triển đến giai đoạn cuối Có khả năng nào Là các người chẩn đoán sai không
Đã phát triển đến giai đoạn cuối Có khả năng nào Là các người chẩn đoán sai không
Tôi đã xem qua rồi Có khả năng nào Là các người chẩn đoán sai không
Tôi đã xem qua rồi Với tình trạng của anh Là các người chẩn đoán sai không Tôi đã xem qua rồi Với tình trạng của anh
Có lẽ là do công việc áp lực cao kéo dài Tôi đã xem qua rồi Với tình trạng của anh
Có lẽ là do công việc áp lực cao kéo dài Do không có chỗ dựa để phát tiết Với tình trạng của anh Có lẽ là do công việc áp lực cao kéo dài
Do không có chỗ dựa để phát tiết Tôi khuyên anh nên tìm ra nguồn gốc trước
Có lẽ là do công việc áp lực cao kéo dài Do không có chỗ dựa để phát tiết Tôi khuyên anh nên tìm ra nguồn gốc trước
Nguồn gốc Do không có chỗ dựa để phát tiết Tôi khuyên anh nên tìm ra nguồn gốc trước Nguồn gốc Đừng ăn tỏi Tôi khuyên anh nên tìm ra nguồn gốc trước
Nguồn gốc Đừng ăn tỏi Anh không nghe thấy sao Nguồn gốc Đừng ăn tỏi Anh không nghe thấy sao
Nhiệt độ cà phê phải ở mức 75 độ Đừng ăn tỏi Anh không nghe thấy sao
Nhiệt độ cà phê phải ở mức 75 độ Và 80 độ Anh không nghe thấy sao
Nhiệt độ cà phê phải ở mức 75 độ Và 80 độ Với bộ dạng này thì đừng làm nữa
Đừng chạm vào Và 80 độ Với bộ dạng này thì đừng làm nữa Đừng chạm vào Tôi không phải kẻ ngốc Với bộ dạng này thì đừng làm nữa Đừng chạm vào Tôi không phải kẻ ngốc
Tiếng gì vậy Đừng chạm vào Tôi không phải kẻ ngốc Tiếng gì vậy Không lẽ là Phạm Vũ Thần
Tôi không phải kẻ ngốc Tiếng gì vậy Không lẽ là Phạm Vũ Thần Chính là tôi Tiếng gì vậy Không lẽ là Phạm Vũ Thần Chính là tôi Tôi biết ngay cái kẻ chua ngoa đáng ghét đó mà
Tôi đây Tôi đây Tôi biết kẻ chua ngoa đáng sợ đó
Tôi biết kẻ chua ngoa đáng sợ đó
Còn một tháng nữa Thế thì Thế thì Xin lỗi, xin lỗi
Không sao, không sao Không sao, không sao
Thưa bà Thưa bà Bác sĩ nói rằng anh Fan rất có thể đã qua đời
Bác sĩ nói rằng anh Fan rất có thể đã qua đời
Anh Fan Anh Fan Chẳng lẽ là Fan Yuchen
Chẳng lẽ là Fan Yuchen Và vụ tai nạn xe hơi này rất có thể không phải là tai nạn
Và vụ tai nạn xe hơi này rất có thể không phải là tai nạn
Người cuối cùng Yuchen gặp là ai
Chắc không phải là tôi chứ Chắc không phải là tôi chứ
Tôi đi trước Tôi đi trước Tôi sẽ tìm anh Tôi sẽ tìm anh
Chồng ơi Chồng ơi Anh không thể bỏ em lại một mình
Anh không thể bỏ em lại một mình
Chồng ơi, nói gì đi chứ Chồng ơi, nói gì đi chứ
Đứa trẻ ngoan Đứa trẻ ngoan Thật khó cho anh vì sự chân thành của anh dành cho Yuchen
Thật khó cho anh vì sự chân thành của anh dành cho Yuchen
Thật là năm triệu Thật là năm triệu
Sau này làm phiền anh chăm sóc Yuchen
Đây là việc tôi nên làm Đây là việc tôi nên làm
Được không Được không Mẹ Mẹ Yuchen có thể gặp được anh
Yuchen có thể gặp được anh Thật là may mắn Thật là may mắn
Anh có thể cuối cùng cũng cho em ra đời không
Tôi vẫn là người thực vật Tôi vẫn là người thực vật
Chúng ta coi như trêu đùa nhau đi
Chụp một bức ảnh nào Chụp một bức ảnh nào
Cho những đồng nghiệp luôn bị anh bắt nạt thấy đi
Tình cảm của hai người này tốt quá